Speaker 1: David, Rudy Giuliani is finally
formally under investigation.
Do you think he will end up serving prison
time?
You know, every time I answer one of these
questions with no, he's not going to go to
prison, I get emails from people saying, David,
you fool, you are making it less likely that
these people will go to prison by saying it's
unlikely they're going to go to prison.
No, I'm not my my show's audience.
This show is just not nearly big enough for
me to say that and for it to have any kind
of affect.
Rudy Giuliani is not going to go to prison.
Rudy Giuliani is 76 years old.
And I'm not saying he shouldn't be investigated
or prosecuted as a result of that.
We now know there's an investigation into
Rudy going on.
His home and office were raided last week.
As we reported, he may have broken lobbying
law.
He may have broken all sorts of laws.
We don't know what's going on with Rudy Giuliani.
It's possible that the investigation will
lead to charges for Rudy Giuliani if there
are charges against Rudy Giuliani.
The most common scenario that I would expect
because of Rudy Giuliani's place in society
and his access and his privilege would be
that there is some kind of a plea agreement
or cooperation agreement.
Michael Cohen, Trump's former lawyer, believes
that Rudy would flip and spill the beans on
Trump because Rudy doesn't want to get in
trouble himself.
So I think that there would be some kind of
plea deal if there's no plea deal.
And it actually and if there is a plea deal,
anything Rudy pleads to would have no jail
time.
There's no doubt about it.
Let's say there was no plea deal and this
thing actually goes to trial.
Is it going to be a guilty verdict?
I don't know if there is a guilty verdict.
We're like four or five maybes in right now.
If there is a guilty verdict, there may be
no jail time anyway associated with that as
per the judge.
And even if by this time when Rudy will be
77 or 78 or 79, who knows how long this thing
could go on even if there is jail time?
I would fully expect that Rudy's lawyer, whoever
it is at the time, who knows how many lawyers
Rudy will have been through at that point
in time.
I would expect Rudy's lawyer would successfully
argue that the sentence be suspended or that
it be home confinement or whatever based on
Rudy's age and possible health situation.
So when you put all of that together, I think
the odds of Rudy ever seeing any prison time
are I mean, I think one in a thousand is when
these when the percentages are so small, it's
hard to make them really tangible.
Is it one in a thousand that Rudy sees jail
time?
I know it's not one in a hundred, is it?
One in two thousand.
But if I were a betting man on even odds,
I'm saying no, you would have to give me some
crazy odds for me to bet that Rudy sees the
inside of a jail cell other than for some
reason unrelated to him being being prosecuted
and charged, if you disagree with me.
Let me know I'm open to having my mind changed,
but I don't see it.
We have a fantastic bonus show today.
What?
Yes, there's an extra show every day for our
members.
Sign up at Join Patricof.